this is so weird it's nice to meet you
[Music]
yeah I feel like tickling is such like a
you do it cuz you know a person and it's
like there's some level of intimacy
involved with it cuz you care about them
so you want to make them laugh there's a
certain point where if you keep tickling
it's weird yeah you get to a certain age
and it's like yeah you shouldn't be
tickling right I hate tickling
as the youngest child I feel like many
can relate when I say that it was used
as a form of torture I'm pretty ticklish
so I'm probably going yeah me too I take
I don't want to slap your anything it's
the weirdest thing that our bodies can
do I am like an awkward hugger and
awkward in general so tickling someone I
don't know how this is going to go
yeah I I feel like a UFC fighter don't
don't look me in the eyes I'm
sorry this is so weird I'm sorry
sorry oh boy all right where would you
like to be tickled I honestly I don't I
don't know I really
don't you got the wings spin on me why I
don't know if I should go soft on I'm
like give me your feet
[Music]
no I can't I don't I'm already ticklish
this is the weirdest
thing I don't even like giving hugs
where are you ticklish I don't know D
okay this this how
that feel um violent yeah sorry if I was
like it was claws it was a lot of claw
action yeah for me the most awkward part
was when he said before he even started
don't make eye contact with me this is
so uncomfortable I just don't like being
touched by strangers I feel more
comfortable actually I feel like I got
to know you a lot better best friends
now I don't think I liked any bit of it
yeah I'm all hot now I'm out of breath
that's not good I don't know you
shouldn't tickle strangers yeah if a
stranger came up to me and
tickled me I'd punch them in the
face you can tickle me if you see me
just just you know I saw you on a video
I figured I should tickle you we got to
stop with the ti like just totally don't
do it to babies to strangers she be ban
to friends lovers dogs end it that's
it